ist dieser brutale polizeieinsatz
gerechtfertigt in krefeld spielen sich
am samstag dramatische szenen ab seit
dem wochenende kursieren diese handy
aufnahmen im netz zu sehen ist eine
polizistin die wiederholt mit der faust
auf einen verdächtigen einprügelt ganze
elf mal holt sie aus
danach kehrt sie den mann heftig zu
boden eine passantin will sich
einmischen wird aber zurückgehalten
zuvor mussten feuerwehr und polizei
anrücken nach angaben von nachbarn soll
der verdächtige seine freundin
eingeschlossen und versucht haben die
wohnung abzufackeln bereits ende
september brannte es hier laut zeugen
sollen oft schreie aus der wohnung zu
hören gewesen sein
die polizei musste mehrfach am rücken
vor der festnahme wegen versuchter
schwerer brandstiftung soll es in der
wohnung zwischen dem verdächtigen und
der polizei zu handgreiflichkeiten
gekommen sein
doch das video beginnt erst als sie
draußen den mann festnehmen wollen gegen
die schlagende beamten wird zurzeit noch
ermittelt sie ist bislang weiterhin
regulär im dienst und aus krefeld mir
nun zugeschaltet meine kollegin dieser
und werft dieser gehören gerade die
polizistin ist noch immer im dienst wie
hat sich die polizei trotzdem bisher zu
diesem fall geäußert die polizei
momentan aus
wie es dazu kommen konnte sind keine
personal personellen maßnahmen eben die
polizistin eingeleitet es wird dem mann
der es der mantel und 40 jährige mann
sitzt momentan in u haft
er ist eines der schweren brandstiftung
tatverdächtig die polizei teilte mit
dass die das bier mit einer metallstange
angegriffen wurden die einsatzkräfte vor
ort
und wenn man sie heften die man auch ein
video sich mehr haben soll
aktuell wird ob er möglicherweise auch
unter drogen stand beziehungsweise auch
anderweitig psychisch so eingeschränkt
war dass er die polizisten angegriffen
haben
ich wollte ein bisschen angegriffen
die polizistin die in dem video zu sehen
war die waffe war nicht zu sehen wir
haben mit augenzeugen gesprochen da
wurde uns mitgeteilt dass sie vor der
ecke und die ecke des hauses stand und
dann auch auf den man eigentlich plagen
hat ganze elf mal gegeben
video gesehen haben der mann wurde
selber auch aus der wohnung raus geholt
aktuell hier ermittler davon aus dass
der mann das feuer selber gelegt hat und
wie du gerade schon gesagt dass es ende
september soll es bereits vor einer
ähnlichen szene gekommen sein
in der nachbarschaft ich uns umgehört
war nicht alles es wurden immer wieder
haben aus der wohnung im hintergrund
promenade spielen wahrgenommen und auch
warum ist das mal entsprechend mit
bezogen rausgekommen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren